[Music]
hey y'all new movie time its matinee 63
you know again this week we've had car
issues and various other things so we
did not get to the theater however we'll
give you a little bonus this time we saw
Netflix movies shutter movies so we're
gonna do for this time because I didn't
realize that we were gonna end up seeing
like four new movies well through movies
and one series so I decided well we'll
just throw them all in there because why
not yeah I decided to revive Jenny's car
$1,100 yeah air AC compressor and break
so we haven't picked it up yet it picked
it up yet so oh my god yeah oh well you
guys would like to contribute yes I did
I mean I I was afraid that it was gonna
be that much yeah yeah because like you
said the AC compressor was the big thing
it was closer to 1200 room but there was
like when we went down there and said
hey check the brakes cuz there was
something wrong with that yeah brake
booster and then needed pads all around
and one two calipers was not doing good
yes I'm started to add up yeah it's okay
though yeah maybe I'm worried about it
yeah so like I said so we didn't get to
the theater I mean there is some like
theater should I want to say I want to
see knives out I want to see some other
stuff what maybe wouldn't go see that
next week all right so the first movie
that we're going to talk about well
another one of those shutter exclusives
that just popped up out of nowhere I
hadn't heard anything about this
apparently it you know I think it
premiered it like you know some of the
film festivals or something like that
but this was actually a cool [ __ ]
movie
this is called the headhunter this was
directed by Jordan Downey yeah and he
made a movie called ThanksKilling yeah
which I have not seen but that's a
really good title he also had made like
some kind of fanfic like fan fiction
films like for the Kritters franchise
which a lot of people really liked um so
I believe this is kind of like his you
know first bigger release or whatever
yeah you have to say yeah this okay you
guys this movies shows you how much the
game has changed this movie cost $30,000
not 30 million 30,000 not 300,000
thirty thousand dollars you'd never know
it by looking at which is nothing and
you'd be making part lawns right thirty
looks like it looks like a multi-million
dollar film it's amazing what the
director did with so little no soy in it
at all it's real kind of tough movie
it's about this medieval warrior who is
[ __ ] around with making healing
potions and [ __ ] and he's living in this
medieval hovel and he's got this armor
and he's like a monster hunter it's like
Skyrim come to life yes out there
hunting these monsters and hanging their
heads up on the walls and one thing
leads to another and he accidentally
creates a monster it's pretty cool yeah
it's pretty cool this story is it's I
mean this is essentially a one-man show
yeah there's only one character well
there's a couple characters right but I
mean this daughter but she doesn't say
much it's essentially a one-man show it
yeah I mean pretty much it's not much
dialogue it doesn't need it's kind of
like a survival adventure like almost
survival adventure kind of like in a D&D
type set like Dungeons and Dragons yeah
like I said it's very Skyrim very yeah
Game of Thrones you know look I was
bloody it's it's bloody and it's got
good it's got good effects and there are
practical effects I didn't see any CG
didn't notice it there's a lot of drone
shots and [ __ ] and out in nature he's
living about in the woods some of its
film but mammoth mountain yeah this I
think it was mostly shot in Portugal
yeah um so but they used like he really
like used the backdrops to great effect
yeah in this I mean this it's like a
whole developed world yeah the thing
about this I have to say no like I said
the main character in it who is not
named he's just called father he's
played by Christopher RIE who well I was
watching this movie I was like he looks
like what would happen if Jason Momoa
and Michael Shannon had a baby yeah he
looks like he has like Michael Michael
Shannon's like real intense like there's
a real intense eyes and like that kind
of that same kind of face but then he's
like real big and buff you know like
Jason Momoa is so he kind of looks like
that but he's but he also kind of kind
of has a yeah he's a Hagrid type of
thing going on here didn't what
good physical shape he does a lot of
cool [ __ ] gets wounded a lot in it tries
to survive they don't show a lot of the
fights with a lot of them they don't
show any of the fights really yes it
really shines they did they show want
the very end when he would the main
monster yeah you know that's you know
they have to they have to control the
budget and instead of that what they do
is instead of showing you all this
combat that's just a bunch of tone and
mood everything seems to be kind of like
fire light and torch lit yeah it's
really nice creepy it's really nice
looking yeah it's creepy it's
essentially like I said it's almost like
a character study I think I read an one
review somewhere that said maybe there
was 12 lines of dialogue and this whole
thing I don't even know if there was
that many but this is kind of like like
I said this is like the epitome of
visual storytelling in the sense that
you're just watching this guy there's a
brief scene with his daughter at the
beginning where she's alive but
apparently this monster and onion own
undisclosed monster has killed her and
so his job is and they never
specifically lay this out but it's
implied that his job is that he is a
monster hunter for this kingdom because
like you see a castle in the distance
and like in one scene you kind of hear
like a you know festival going on or
something like very far away yeah and
every now and then he hears like a horn
and then like that wakes mom he's like
oh well there must be a new monster in
the population down right yeah like I
said all you see the monsters like
basically he'll go he'll hear the horn
it'll get his armor on and he'll leave
like on his horse and then he'll come
back and then he'll put the head on the
spike it is there's like a Yeti there's
like a werewolf werewolf there's like a
zombie looking thing there's like all
these different months so all of the
monsters ever are real yes universe yeah
most most all the major monster food
groups are represented exactly yeah all
the traditional stuff there's also I saw
some like goblin heads and yeah there's
a trail goblin head and you know if you
kind of like in that you're kind of
coming up from the Dungeons & Dragons
area you'll you'll recognize some of
stuff is kind of based on air all Otis's
drawings from like you know was that the
Monster Manual yeah it's very much like
a dress Monster Manual so so very much
like the first probably
the first two-thirds of the movie you're
just kind of watching this single dude
you know and you feel like a medieval
Mad Max yeah it's like he doesn't talk
he doesn't cuz there's no one to talk to
his daughter is dead
he talks at her grave a couple of times
that's about it is so it's like it's
just him going out killing monsters and
then sometimes like making a potion that
like heals him that's just kind of like
a it almost seems like it now it's like
a black magic kind of component although
like I said everything is very grounded
in reality it's very the the you know
the production design like the set
design and everything like that is
really really good like inside of his
cabin it's just like it's all dirty and
scummy and like there's blood dripping
down it's like yeah it does major in
Dungeons and Dragons term he's kind of
like a cross class character he's kind
of like a fighter and a magic user maybe
he'd be considered like a ranger yeah or
you know he can even like that he can do
some magic but it's potions he can make
a potion yeah make I think he made a
couple different kinds Denis or is it
just one kind of potion I couldn't well
it was just like this kind of like black
and green goop that actually plays into
the plot yeah yeah and he keep it keep
it in jars and stuff but yeah it's
pretty cool now the thing about this
mutant like I could see how some people
might find it frustrating that none of
the battles with the monsters are shown
just the aftermath is shown like where
he comes back his cabinet he's wounded
and but he's you know been the victor
because he throws a little head in the
bag on the floor and just puts the new
head on the thing um you know what I
mean but in a way I liked that better
you don't way to need to see you don't
need to see it like yeah it was because
of the budget and everything like that
but in a way I think it made it better
because you kind of got a sense of this
dudes this is like his life this is like
his routine this job to him it's just
like kind of like a job right and it's
just like oh there I go I got to go kill
another one and it just comes back and
sticks it on the thing and it's like you
know what I mean but there's still like
kind of a sense of weight to his
character because what he wants to do
every time he goes out like to kill
these monsters he keeps hoping that it's
gonna be the specific monster that
killed his daughter because he's trying
to get revenge and stuff like that so
like I said this is one that's it really
doesn't need any dialogue it doesn't
a lot of flashy CG or a lot of special
effects or anything like that because so
much of the story is told through just
the details like on the screen you know
what I mean when you understand the
budget of the movies was thirty
thousands movies like a ten out of ten
I'm stuff like that [ __ ] Blood Money
yeah if you didn't know that was my
puppet if you didn't know it was only a
thirty thousand dollar budget you still
would probably give it a seven out of
ten eight out of ten yeah yeah
artistically the tone the moods they're
that acting the sets the costumes just
the way is shot the storytelling the
special effects
there's just nothing wrong with it
that's about it as good I was very
impressed like I said the only come I
can see people complaining like though
you don't get to see the monster fights
or it's slow at the end but yeah but in
a way like I think that worked in its
favor because it gave it you got a real
sense of this character as this is just
his job and it's just like a routine for
him with what they delivered if he'd had
a hundred thousand dollar budget you
probably could have thrown a couple more
yeah monster fight scenes in it but
would that have improved the movie a lot
I don't think that Ryan I don't think it
needed it I mean I really don't as good
the way it was yeah I liked it the way
it was I mean like I said your mileage
may vary but this is just a sign of the
future that you know you don't need
these big Hollywood studios and [ __ ]
tons of money just have to know what to
do
cameras and drones and all that stuff
it's a lot cheaper than it used to be
and you know you can edit a lot of that
stuff at home yeah you know on just a PC
with good software it's you know this is
just gonna be the way to go from here on
out yeah and you sell this stuff to
shutter or or you know Netflix they're
like eh yeah like I said that these just
I mean basically you make it it makes
the round of a Film Festival and usually
gets picked up if it's good so scrappy
asked movies I grew up with his crappy
ass horror movies I grew up with during
the 80s even the bad ones had a million
dollar budget at least well yeah and I
said what he ended up with might have
been fun to watch but they were shitty
yeah they're fun yeah they're funded
[ __ ] they had a kind of goofy tone to
him you were
supposed to take him seriously or
anything this movie serious serious it's
like a serious movie yeah it's a lot
more serious than in 1980s two million
dollar movie yeah because that was crap
and two million dollars was nothing bad
there was nothing like that
yeah like probably the the worst movie
that was watchable that I grew up with
that was like yeah that was that's
that's a cheap movie but you know it's
not total [ __ ] would have been like
galaxy of terror yeah that James Cameron
we did not do in this special effect
yeah I was that movie though that yeah
there's a very watchable low-budget
movie for the time but that was still
priced six million dollars it probably
was yes yeah I don't know our fan but I
don't know a fan it was still Millions
yeah that's Corman when it runs a Roger
Corman it was yeah it's probably three
years alien ripoff oh yes this is Malin
ripoff Sid Haig yeah yeah I forgot he
was that yeah he was in it girl got
raped by a big old caterpillar well I
remember that scene that was very
memorable did Hayes arm tried to kill
him yeah that's I live and die by the
crystals we just watch that night slips
from it either or something you just saw
clothes from it like I hit that movie on
blu-ray but that was an eighties cheap
movie yeah alright this movie looks a
lot better than that one
over 30,000 I did you know that it cost
$30 I mean I figured it was probably
like a low-budget but I I it did not
occur to me there were man at low
budgets up there with like Mandy yeah
you know in watch ability yeah and
enjoyably like I said I think a lot of
it too not only like the amazing
locations and like the cinematography
and everything like with all the kid the
firelight and everything was like really
beautiful but also that that [ __ ]
actor man I hope he [ __ ] does some
other [ __ ] because he said so much like
with his body movements and his facial
Hanuman's
it had nothing hardly it had a very good
tone it had a very eerie kind of a dirty
tone in a certain way because he was
dealing with a lot of stuff that was
rotten yeah and it was you could tell it
was kind of cold yeah it's very good I
mean yeah and he was kind of living in
or in a certain way well yes little cuz
it's a medieval Aaron he's got that he's
living in this kind of like house with a
thatched roof on I don't even think it
was stone was it or was it stung with a
thatched roof on top of it might have
been stone might have it had sent River
arcane looking stuff in there you know
wooden cabinets and jars and big
collection of rotten heads not in
Monster heads inside inside the wall
just living with it yeah yeah no it's
like this is one of the times that I'm
really glad that movies aren't
scratchansniff yeah because I'm sure
this head is but yeah seriously um I
think this is on other VOD platforms too
it's probably like an Amazon Prime [ __ ]
like maybe you can run it on YouTube I'm
not sure but shutter has it they just
added it a couple like a week ago
and this was actually a very very
pleasant surprise yes check out a 10
yeah this is this a fantastic movie like
I said yeah best bang for the buck yeah
it goes like our movie you can't beat
this don't go into it like think it's
gonna be like an action movie oh god it
is it sort of is but not at the end like
most of its like off screen yeah you
know I mean you know total yeah it's all
about tone yeah but yeah I would I would
definitely definitely recommend it
you
so the next thing we watched I was
actually gonna watch this anyway but
then one of our listeners Eric the same
guy that says the Piggly Wiggly panic
yeah for a couple ways back he sent me
an email it's like you have to see the
confession killer on Netflix which is
actually a documentary series I think it
was five episodes did we show the Piggly
Wiggly bag on the show we did yeah from
other countries that don't believe us
that there is a you know let him see
them yeah and a lot of a lot depict the
piglets wiggle wiggle their wiggling
wiggling trying to hold this is series a
Netflix original series called
confession killer and it was good it's
about old what's-his-name really and
really Lucas and this one just gets
crazier and crazier crazy every episode
it just gets crazier if you haven't seen
it go go check it out yeah like if you
don't know this story of Henry Lee Lucas
for a time in the 1980s they I mean he
confessed he they got him on well he
killed his mom in 1960 they can dig no
better happened yeah I was a kid he got
convicted of that now he um his mom
sounded pretty bad yeah viola veal yeah
it was her name yeah I think she was a
prostitute er yeah turning tricks a lot
of dads in a damn wheelchair huh yeah
making a watch and then yes beaten it
she beat him up pretty bad when he got
big enough to [ __ ] retaliate and
killed her yeah he was 23 years old when
he killed her yeah so he did actually I
think he got 15 years for that now he
probably did kill he had a 15 or 16 year
old girlfriend named Becky Powell um you
know later on and he also had a like an
older woman who was a his landlord named
Kate red she was 82 I thought that what
weren't they related been in the
landlord weren't they no okay no he
killed both of them no I X that he
probably killed Kate rich because she
found out about him killing yeah a
girlfriend right so they never didn't
mention the girlfriend
family did she have one yeah like did
the parents and something there yeah I'm
not really sure but it's like well she's
like 13 and he's like 40 so she was 15
15 15 or 16 and she's dating Lucas and
Lucas was in his 40s all right I think
so yeah I don't really remember I think
the parents would be kind of against
that yeah 15 out of 16 yeah I don't know
different time back then
yes well alright but yeah so when he got
caught for those two murders which they
suspect he probably did those because I
mean he did get convicted to the mother
body because he led police to where the
bodies were yeah and everything he said
about the crime is correct however once
he was that he was at a court appearance
for the Kate rich murder and he suddenly
apropos of nothing just blurted out in
the courtroom what about those hundred
other women that I killed yeah and
they're like what and everyone's like
you know record scratch what yeah what
about all I'm other hundred ones I
killed
yeah yeah but very quickly went to wear
like 303 600 and any case you gave to
him he'd confessed to it it got [ __ ]
ridiculous the Texas Rangers were
involved they were using him to clear
his books to clear their their their
their their their Case Files with people
from other states were covered cops from
other states were coming using him to
confess and this he just made a living
out of disgrace and that's what's kind
of like what's sad about this whole
terrible saga is that here's this guy I
mean Henry Lee Lucas was not a [ __ ]
genius it's like he had like an 87 IQ he
like had that weird droopy eye it wasn't
good looking and his boyfriend was even
dumber and it ya hung out with oddest
tool yeah and all this other stuff but
it got to a point then in the 1980s
where he was kind of like built up as
you know the you know the world's most
prolific serial killer because he was
confessing to everything yeah and the
thing about it is that you know not to
[ __ ] on the Texas Rangers but I feel
like they got a little
over-enthusiastic about wanting to clear
their cases because it looks bad when
you have unsolved murders on your books
you know people don't get promoted
people don't you know various other
things don't happen there's a lot of
like politics involved so they figured
if this dumbass was going to confess to
every single murder that they put in
front of his face and all he was asking
in return was hey can I have a
strawberry milkshake and have the
cigarettes I want and can I walk around
the jail without handcuffs on yeah then
they were like well fine they didn't
check well they also took him places
they had to take him to these locations
so he had on the road constantly having
fun and he's in the back of car watch
and everything yeah sitting in a cell
and I'm sure they ran him through the
drive the miles drive through him got
him a Big Mac and [ __ ] like that
what I liked about this series you know
it's not so much about the case and
we're talking really more about the
series the way the series tells the
story with each additional episode how
many of them were there verified five
episodes each additional episode it kind
of like ups the crazy that you can't
believe that this shit's actually
happened and I knew something about this
case yeah but you can't believe it some
of the [ __ ] that he's saying and you
can't believe what the cops are
believing believe the one thing that
shocked me the most like I said I knew
something about Henry Lee Lucas cuz you
know they made Henry port River serial
killer about him which is kind of
exaggerated but ya know disturbing movie
it is very disturbing Michael Rooker was
great but you can watch that and realize
that that's all lies that's all based
upon the lies that he a notice artists
you know came up with they came up with
it's the the thing that the thing about
the thing about Lucas is that the
stories that he would tell couldn't have
happened the jamming he's not a very
physical physically imposing guy okay
he's not mentally very fast you could
tell that he's not somebody who could
really deal with a change challenging
and changing environment to be he would
claim to be a drifter
yeah but records I'll show that no he
kept a job during all this so how could
you drive all over and that's nice news
that he didn't commit some of the crimes
that he said he committed
and work record yeah you know speeding
tickets and stuff like that like in a
state across the country women who
supposedly did that he didn't have the
wherewithal to even go on the road
really he stayed at home yeah I mean I
mean moved from state to state but it's
like he couldn't live on the road for
months and months at the time all right
and kill enough victims to get enough
money off of them he couldn't come in
contact with enough women that had money
on them on a daily basis yeah you know I
mean I think this you have you'd have to
kill several people a day yeah you know
I mean and it had had money on him to
continue his travels yeah and to cover
his expenses in his food it's just not
plausible well one of my most kind of
shocking you know moments in this series
was when cuz of course the Texas Rangers
are like saying you know oh maybe they
didn't commit some but he you know we
took his word for it they were trying to
like cover their ass but the thing is
later on I mean even back in the 80s you
know there were some other law
enforcement agencies were like hey wait
a minute now it's like they just can't
be and somebody took like a map and
showed they're like okay well they made
a list of all the crimes that he had
confessed to and they're like this is
how he would have had to do and they
show just like these lines to go back
and forth back forth this is like in a
couple hours there's like there's no way
there's yes gas food hotels all that
[ __ ] cost money to go on a tour like
that yeah you have to be bringing in a
certain amount of money where is the
second money come from it's just
ridiculous when you actually look at the
huge scope of what they're talking about
what he would have had to do now if you
were an attractive guy who is
intelligent and fast and strong and you
were a kid looking like a Ted Bundy type
maybe you could do it but these guys
were losers I mean you know these were
head Bundy I mean he killed 30 and yeah
that's a lot yeah I mean six 600 come on
yeah and and even even a even a
brokedown crackhead would run from those
two as soon as you saw him or smelled
him yeah you know they just said he
smells a they smell terrible
he only had like four teeth so it's not
like he's gonna be able to approach rich
women
that have money in their purses on a
constantly on a constant but it's just
how those yeah you know it and you know
he's physically overpowered him he
doesn't he did he was not really even a
strong guy yeah he was just a lot us was
kinda big but not really yeah you know
maybe the two of them together could do
but the whole money factor yeah they
would have met in and they guys like
that normally victimized like
bottom-of-the-barrel
beggar type prostitute junkie women they
don't have a dime yeah
you kill him you don't get any money out
of them that's not gonna fuel your
travels yeah you know it's just the
story they're telling us just told the
cops knew that it was fake I think they
knew and they just which bummed me out a
lot because in a lot of ways like when
they looked at a lot of the interview
footage and [ __ ] like that later it's
clear that whether they were intending
to do this or not the law enforcement
agents true the Texas Rangers were
feeding him information or kind of
leading him you know leading questions
leading him down a certain path they let
him look at crime scene photos
they let him look at the police reports
in some cases he knew what the
confession no what it should look like
he knew drugs they drove him to where
the body they thought the body was it's
like you know what I mean so and they
didn't check it's like they didn't cross
check could he have been in this shape
when they could because he said he
committed them all over the country they
didn't really think to cross check and
then later when they actually did that
they determined that there was just no
way now did he kill three people his mom
his girlfriend usually I think that's
all he killed probably yeah
he was convicted ultimately of 11
murders including at least one that they
found out later on through DNA that he
did not commit you know it was just this
weird thing where he was like trying to
get the death penalty for a while
because I guess because he maybe felt
bad about but the thing about it is that
as dumb as he was he wasn't that dumb
because he seemed really good at like
cold reading you know what I mean and
manipulating look the cops into getting
what he wanted you know what I mean so
it's like he had a structure in his life
for the first time so he was just like
giving them what they wanted and he
seemed to be really good at doing that
funny thing that they didn't get it they
didn't go into oddest to much I'm not
really there's just like a couple of
minutes yeah I don't know who he killed
yeah or what to do he said he when they
would ask him you know what happened and
this he goes to use he would be like
well uh what does Henry say whatever
Henry says that's what it that's what
happened what is what is Henry said he
was just basically just yelling whatever
yeah Henry says I don't think he killed
anybody with with Henry I don't think
yeah it's like I'm kind of doubting it I
would have to look more into audist
specifically because like you said they
didn't really go into him a lot they had
some on him they had something on him
but that was probably all he did
whatever they had on him yeah so you
know I don't believe in this they went
up on this cross country of murders
murder spree for like eight years yeah
like killing six hundred people I don't
I don't buy that I don't think that I
don't I don't think anybody buys I don't
think they had the faculties to do it no
no and you know the thing about this is
that it this is like it's so fascinating
because like you said it gets crazier
and crazier yeah and even then trying to
get him out of prison yeah it's like
even though I knew something about this
case I didn't know like all the details
of it and like all the details of the
crimes he confessed to so it was like
[ __ ] crazy and they do kind of go
into a you know in the end they do kind
of go into a little bit of because now
they've started doing DNA on some of
these cold cases and some of the ones
that he confessed to you know as of this
series coming out they have actually 20
cases I believe that he that were among
the ones that he confessed to they have
determined through DNA that they were
perpetrated by other yeah Jules yeah he
killed his mom alright they did that
yeah he killed his little girlfriend and
he killed that old lady yeah and I think
that's all pretty much that's pretty
much it
I mean I think the Texas Rangers think
that he might have done a couple more
because that oh he led us to the bodies
and stuff like that but you can't trust
it like I said I can't trust that
because they were they open him they
were kind of like feeding him ammonia
and I think I think they were feeding
him information so yes so definitely
this is a really really good yeah you
guys hehe was just confess and be
he got pretty legs and privileges and a
lot of attention and attention and
nobody ever paid any attention to either
him or oddest yeah they were all of a
sudden now they're on TV they would say
anything and they did not want out of
prison didn't want to go anywhere they
were having a good time in prison so
there yes they got treated pretty good I
mean they living in jail they lived
better in prison than they did when they
were free exactly so why would he want
to go on out yeah yeah
so yeah this year were bombs basically
yeah yeah so basically I mean if you're
in a true-crime you've got to see this
[ __ ] like I said it just gets crazier
and crazier and it's not only you know
it focuses more on less about the crimes
I guess and more on him and like the
crazy [ __ ] and like kind of the you know
the dynamic between him and the Texas
Rangers and like all the other people
trying to like call them outs and yeah
there's no way you could have done it
so it's depressing but it's also like
really fast everybody look into it yeah
it's like kind of funny like it looked
okay but yeah so you know definitely
check this one out it's on Netflix at
the moment
you
the next one we saw was also a shutter
exclusive this is called perfect yeah if
you like Mandy you'd like this one
thought about its color palette in the
way it's shot it kind of reminds me of
that movie I don't know if it's some of
the same people involved but this is a
good movie so it's odd like that like
Mandy was
it's very okay you guys it's very very
very our Tea Party yeah even more like
Mandy it's more like that that director
who's I can't reverse name right now
he's he's Greek any but it's like um his
first movie beyond the black rainbow
this is much more like that yeah about
like it's a high-tech theme kind of like
body modification this is what they're
doing yeah they're cutting pieces of
themselves and taking it out putting
these artificial things in there this
looks like a little dam cubes of
gelatinous yeah and crystal and it
changes them and this has happening
inside kind of like a mental institution
or something like that it's like it said
it unspecified time in the future the
main character who's like a teenage well
I guess he's like 18 19 early 20s he
doesn't have a name he's just called
vessel 13 his mother he murders his
girlfriend at the beginning and his
mother puts him in this Institute some
kind of prison it's like but not really
but it's cuz it's like a really fancy
house yes it's like it's like a
beautiful pool yeah stuff yeah it's like
a prison but instead of it being a
prison you would know if it's more like
a paradise yeah and they're trying to
re-engineer yours yeah they're basically
trying to like put you on a different
evolutionary path or something it's not
super clear not real clear exactly what
you're doing is in the future you know
we can't understand it I guess this is
kind of like you know and then there's
Lucy yeah he'll like cut pieces of
himself out like and lift it out and put
it and then put it in me like he's
trying to like [ __ ] but it's like
okay so if you liked this is kind of a
cross between beyond the black rainbow
Bladerunner 2049 hope gave me a little
bit of that vibe upgrade a little bit of
upgrade but you know slightly yeah and a
new retro wave music video yeah
yeah it has a lot of those red creepy
tones you see out of like Mandy yeah is
that like a lot of really really trippy
yeah it's kind of like you're under the
influence of some kind of [ __ ] LSD or
something it's like yeah it is very much
like that so like I said there is a plot
but hard to understand I don't think
you're gonna know what's going on I'm
not really even sure the screenwriter
knows what's going on I don't know I
think he did I didn't really know what
was going on all the time I was no I
didn't understand it yeah it was good
though I'd have to see it again yeah
it's very artistic like I said this
reminded me very very strongly and
beyond the black rainbow in in the sense
that you're watching it and it's really
cool and you kind of know that something
is going on it has to do with this
institute and it's like you know we
don't have that evolving or something
but it's like but really at the end of
it you're like what the [ __ ] was going
on with that it's like it's in the
future we don't have we don't know the
[ __ ] technological context I don't
know where any I don't understand how a
solid cube like a plastic kind of like
an ice cube can be put inside of a
person you just definitely not enough
room but it went in anyway well yeah and
then somehow it changed him
it was weird except I had to see that it
was working yeah I don't see it a couple
of times because he was like a killer
and they were trying to like genetically
engineer that out of him and I think it
wasn't working right you know I mean I
think that's kind of what the whole now
the weird thing about this is that
apparently the original title for this
was puberty which I'm not sure if that
gives you any insight into what it's a
metaphor for or symbol for or anything
this is cotton I looked at like some of
the reviews and like some and apparently
people really really hate this movie
like I think I think it only got like 17
percent on Rotten Tomatoes or something
like that it got like a couple of cool
reviews um you know some some of the
reviews said you know it looks really
cool there's like really good it's like
a cool like weird midnight movie type of
vibe to it but it's like it doesn't
really make a lot of sense it's like
it's very very very already very
pretentious which and I'm not gonna
argue with that one of the one of the
best reviews I saw then think was from
slant
and the guy said he's like this is the
sort of purposefully inscrutable
wandering disconnected symbolic and
highly precious mood bath yeah that
you'll either adore or loathe yeah that
is a very very active I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure it makes
sense we just don't understand it maybe
we just can't understand there's a line
in the movie where cuz there's a thing
where he I mean he kills his girlfriend
of the beginning and he goes to this
Institute and I guess his mom had been
there like at some point when she was
younger and he meets this girl named
Sarah is Sarah the girlfriend that he
killed they kind of implied that she's
not but they don't there's this she is
but they don't really kind of do
anything with that I don't think I was
thinking in my it might be virtual
reality maybe to where he's not really
there yes in a matrix basically and all
the little body modifications and the
cubes he's putting himself are actually
more kind of like programs yeah they're
trying to reprogram him that's what I
thought was going on that doesn't say
yeah that's a that's a good read that
that that nothing in it was real yeah it
was all happening in his mouth that yeah
that would make things man that's what I
thought was going on yeah because a lot
of the [ __ ] that happens like a London
he has like a lot of visions and stuff
like that too of like because remember
all his visions he was having at him is
like an old like a caveman or so like he
had the white [ __ ] all over him and he
was like tying the girlfriend up and
burning her alive and [ __ ] like that
yeah so there was a lot of that but see
there was a line in the movie that this
girl Sarah who may or may not have been
his dead girlfriend and she said to him
at one point that because he was kind of
like flirting with her sort of in a
weird language sort of way but um you
know she had a line where it won't work
between us because she essentially was
on like a way higher like evolutionary
plane than em and she didn't want to
like you know I mean so maybe that's the
movie telling the audience that the
movie is at a way higher evolutionary
way than the audience is well if you
don't understand it then kind of what I
thought is remembered thx 1138 they get
ta they get sex and they're they've got
him in a big white room and they're
trying to reprogram his thinking and
he's just like sitting there and there
and make him do that's what I thought
probably the reality like a chx rot 1138
really he's in a cell and they're
messing with his brain that could be and
what you're seeing this is you're seeing
the hallucination of the reengineer
that's kind of what I thought I was
going like none of this is real he's in
the matrix that kind of makes that okay
you know that's what I could read it
that way I mean I have to see it again
cuz like I said now I too many
violations of physics happening true and
too many visions so it had to been
happening in his mind and he's in some
kinda there was no reality there wasn't
a reality in the movement I thought it
was all inside his head he was in some
kind of cell somewhere and they were
reprogramming him I think I liked you
better with that interpretation no
that's what I thought yes I mean I dug
this movie but I can see how most people
would probably hate it you know it's not
for the average person like I said it's
one of those ones where you're like I'm
not really sure what I just watched but
it was kind of cool I got to go into it
knowing that and probably you know
probably some mind-altering substances
might yet might help you go into this
knowing that the movie is not a kind of
portray realism I think that probably it
probably will yeah kind of like it erase
her head or something yeah this is
definitely a weird yeah [ __ ] it's
weird me but yeah it's good I liked it
it was cool but yeah so it's on shudder
at the moment like I said I think it
premiered at some festivals last year
but it only came out in wide release
this year so if that sounds like
something that you would be into then by
all means check it out
you
now for our bonus fourth movie we
weren't gonna actually do three movies
but then we ended up last night a little
early evening and we got a little drink
and I said you know what I'm gonna sit
down and I'm gonna watch the new Martin
Scorsese movie the Irishman which is a
commitment because it's three and a half
hours long
yeah but it's a good three and a half
hours it did not seem that long to me
kind of like kind of like Godfather Part
2 or Godfather one you know this is kind
of like the Expendables version of a
game they're all [ __ ] old old guys old
gangsters they were old weaving when
they're young in this movie because well
they're all da they're de-aged but they
D age them down to about 50 probably
either honestly no I have to say the D
aging a very good noticeable yeah but
after like a couple minutes I didn't
notice it yeah I think the best da Jun
that I have ever seen so far you see how
old these guys really are nowadays man
you know these [ __ ] are old man may
eighties 70s well happens to ever yeah
they're looking around looking pretty
rough yeah pretty much all of them
there's a few of them that don't look
that bad but yeah this is gonna be their
last hoorah I think well in that way
like so I'm really glad that like Martin
Scorsese got like all of I mean this is
an amazing [ __ ] cast it's a good yeah
it's all-star cast and it is it is a
good gangster movie it's like Goodfellas
kind of but yeah goodfeathers and
Goodfellas in Godfather me yeah it's
more like um you know there's violence
in it there's more but it's more like a
meditation on because you know you know
the Frank Sheeran character he's played
by Robert De Niro it's like this is him
as an old guy recalling [ __ ] that
happened you know in the early in the
late 60s early 1970s we were like we're
calling his life so it's almost like a
more reflective yeah Goodfellas yeah and
the main topic is Jimmy Hoffa yeah I
mean it's about it's fun white Aaron's
point of view yeah who Jimmy Hoffa was
what happened to him and how that [ __ ]
went down the Teamsters and all the
gangsters that were around
it's a good flick a real good movie
Scorsese get it did a good job on it
it's got some good story tellings that
there was a couple little things at Cana
I think was a mistake there's one
there's one scene where just like in
Goodfellas what's his name Robert De
Niro talks to the audience remember that
and I'm gonna tell him I don't know if
he did it he did it narration or if he
did it well he was narrating because
he's wrong he was talking to an unseen
person about his right and also he was
talking to the audience to explain what
a certain phrases meant type a deal and
they only do it in the very beginning
the movie never does it again so it kind
of threw the tone off you know what I
mean you could do that or don't do it
cuz then cut in and they did that in
Goodfellas yeah but they consistently
did that in Goodfellas ya know you know
where a character would explain
something it was a written Ray Liotta
would explain things to the audience
that that you know because gangsters did
certain things yeah
but they only did it like once or twice
in the very beginning and I thought that
was weird that he didn't do it again
yeah I mean I feel like there was more
of it through there but it wasn't I mean
they didn't really go overboard with the
narration wrong cuz like I said the
whole frame story is he is you know his
character he's playing Frank Sheeran who
was a real guy and he's like in a old
folks home he's telling someone about
his involvement in the killing another
thing that threw me out of it the movie
is that there's a there's a scene where
they got DeNiro Dee aged in kind of like
a fight scene where he's beaten up yeah
he curb stomps like a groceries the
grocery store guy that grabbed his
daughter or something they got him Dee
aged into his maybe his late 50s I think
he's supposed to be well I think the
real Jean oh man the real guy was
supposed to be 37 okay I think the DA
aged version of him doing this fight
look he he looks old he looks like in
his late 50s in a bad late 50s
all right and he curb stomps us other
dude but the body languages
obviously that of an old man all right
I would not shown that on screen or used
a body double to do it because just the
way he's moving he's moving like a dude
that has osteoporosis that's that yeah
you know stomping on a guy just it
looked at cartoonish and very very fake
I would have used a body double and then
put and then digitally potentially put
his face on there yeah cuz they can do
that I could tell that that was an old
man like a man a dude in his 70s er yeah
like a dude and I could tell it was De
Niro's body yeah I could you know I
could read his body language but I could
also tell it was a 70 something year old
denier less and it just he looked very
frail yeah but that's kind of like I
mean other than that and like I said the
D aging the faces and stuff like that
did not bother me in the slightest it's
not distracting I didn't find it
distracting I didn't even in fact they
did it so subtly in some scenes because
this kind of skips back and forth in
time a lot so in some cases I couldn't
really I don't know it's just it didn't
bother me like after a while but yeah I
can see that that one scene where you
actually see him full-body like so yeah
yeah it didn't look good yeah so they
probably should have just left that out
should have left it out he used a body
double and put the face on there yeah
but other than that I mean that was that
yeah the movie was really good that's
kind of like my only complaint those are
the only two things that took me out of
it yeah and DeNiro can't he can still
act he did pull the roll off I just
didn't think he didn't he doesn't he he
didn't have the correct he didn't have a
prowess really the physical the
physicality you need to pull that one
scene off they should have used somebody
else for that that was that's the only
problem
yeah the movie the rest of it the movies
great yeah I mean like I said this is
based on true story I think the book
came out in 2004 and it's called I heard
you paint houses um which is also what
it looks like this movie is called
because I think the opening credits just
said I heard you paint houses it didn't
say the irishman until the end so I
think while they were working on the
movie that's what they were gonna call
it because that's what the book is
called um you know I heard you paint
houses being like hey I heard you kill
people you know what's the
that uh did played half again Al Pacino
yeah machine oh did a great job he was
fast together and Al Pacino is actually
held together pretty well no he's
younger than the others of the guys at
yeah a little bit a little bit younger B
yeah he's still looking pretty good
yeah I think they da just him as well
maybe but um I don't know maybe not I
think I think that might have been him
yeah but uh cuz I think he was supposed
to be it I think back in the olden days
yeah okay he was a little bit older than
everybody else so I think they just
showed him at his problem I don't know
yeah I don't know well that's in a way
that's kind of good because you're not
really sure when they're da da and
they're not you know what I mean even
though I was kind of looking out for it
yeah because I had heard about it I but
I think else Pacino was da J but it's
not super noticeable yeah if he was D
aged it wasn't by much I don't you think
but of course he pulled you know he
pulled that role off
he was it yeah that was great in this
yeah he's great he was great they would
get every good and the thing about it is
that like I said this is almost like I
you know I want to say it's more
reflective it's more meditative not
really there's still like action that
there's violence in it these are
gangsters you know there's people
getting whacked there's all that kind of
stuff but since you're seeing it from
you know the Frank Sharon's character
and he's telling it you know regretfully
I guess almost like how it happened
yeah so there's more and this is uh this
is more so it's a lot kind of
emotionally resonant more also much
funnier it was very funny like it had
some a couple scenes that we were just
like busted up laughing yeah like it has
like a really lot of great humor the
pacing of this like I said you would
think of thirteen at three and a half
hours holy [ __ ] but it's like it really
did not seem that long at all because
you just got so engrossed in you know
this story of like all this kind of like
complicated [ __ ] that's going on you
know they're all a bunch of friends and
they're all [ __ ] making money doing
illegal stuff and when some of them
start [ __ ] up you got to cover your
own ass sometimes you have to kill dudes
can't them going to prison but if you
watch a movie a lot they bring it on
themselves
mostly yeah in a lot of ways you're just
kind of seeing like you know and they
try to help him like I don't do this you
know this isn't gonna go oh you guys are
never gonna do none to me that kind of
deal you're not now but then at the end
of guys all [ __ ] all [ __ ] Joe
Pesci's character has to say is it is
what it is what it is and you know what
that means yeah tell him it is we're
gonna plug you yeah
whether you know whether or not cuz like
I said this is based on a book where
Frank Sheeran basically came out and
said what happened to Jimmy Hoffa like
why they never found him he's like yeah
I'm the guy that killed him and [ __ ]
like that but you know no one knows
whether his account of of what happened
is true you know what I mean this is
probably true but it probably I mean you
know some other you know researchers
have come out and said oh you know this
done the other they've like shown how
maybe it couldn't be true but you know
yeah I'd always thought that what they
had done with the body has had it
underneath the dam was a stadium because
yeah that was the legend that that was a
legend because some of those mob guys
were connected with the construction of
a stadium around that time and maybe
they put him you know I mean underneath
when they were pouring foundations you
know making things that but that'd be a
good place to put it but the movie has a
much better explanation for what
happened for what they did with the body
and what I see but you know once I see
it that way like yeah that's that's more
in line one line what they did in the
past they would have done yeah you know
which I don't know if I should spoil
their I'm not gonna spoil that yeah but
you know what I mean so like I said if
you've read the book or you for anything
about this I mean this movie it did have
a limited theatrical release but okay so
this is something that happens this
movie costs like one hundred fifty nine
million dollars to make now you know
it's probably it's one of his most
Martin Scorsese's most expensive movies
now he got like money from a bunch of
production companies got a bunch of
money from Netflix to make it and then
there was like a huge controversy
because he wanted to release it in
theaters but then release it to VOD like
not that you know fard the patented far
in the future like he wanted
only to be like a week or two apart and
all your big movie chains
you know AMC Cineplex all that and they
said no we want at least two months lead
time we want to have two months to play
it in the theater and then you can show
it at home and they didn't want to do
that so there was like this kind of big
deal about you know most of the major
chains would not show the movie because
they didn't feel like Netflix was giving
them long enough to show it in the
theater before they put it on streaming
so there was like a big kind of
controversy about this and in this
country and in Europe however it did get
a limited theatrical release and made
you know a few million dollars just and
even though it was on only 500 screens
in the US because that's pretty much all
you can get if you if the chains won't
show your movie is you get five hundred
screens so it actually did really well
some of the you know showings in like
New York and LA and stuff like that were
sold out so I you know I don't know if
this is actually gonna make its money
back even though it was one of the
highest you know Netflix I think it was
maybe the second highest you know
viewership of like the first like I
think 16 17 % of their viewership
watched it in the first week that it
came out which was like really really
good and it's also gotten I think it got
like nominated for like Golden Globes
it's got like all kind of it's got
pretty much universal acclaim this will
be this one will go down as a classic
I think so too it's like this is it'll
be like Godfather 1 & 2 yeah it'll be
like Goodfellas so it'll be like casino
it if you're into gangster movies this
is it but this one is kind of like the
last hurrah of that generation of actor
yeah they just talked about a move make
a movie like this again we're using
those guys there's not a time I don't
think I don't think they'll be
interested in doing it no probably not
like I said that I mean Joe Pesci did
not want to do yeah another movie
because he's pretty much retired it's
gonna take another 5 years to make a
movie like this at least and
five years from now man those guys are
gonna be a [ __ ] but I mean [ __ ] man
think about it Martin Scorsese is in his
70s yeah and for him to come out and
make this movie like this is a biscuit
Oliver epic yeah
gangster movie yeah and it's just it's
so good and it was just like like I said
I was never bored
I was super engrossed in the story and
engrossed in these characters and like
all the acting and it is amazing and
it's just like such a great [ __ ]
movie so for somebody that you know of
that age to come out and be like you
know mic drop and like make a movie like
this yeah
what's funny is that on the downside of
this whole situation is that there
aren't very many actors that have the
street cred and the star power to do
roles like this yeah these you know that
these these actors are all one-of-a-kind
actors I can't think of if you're gonna
the gangster movies of the future just
aren't gonna have that kind of impact
nothing I guess it depends I mean you
never know like where the dude the dude
who played the right-hand man to the
woman in Luke Cage so we just saw him
again he could play a gangster what was
that guy's name I can't remember the
actors that actor the guy that played
shades that was a guy that plays shades
they probably do it there aren't many
guys out there with the name recognition
yeah like I said there's a lot of guys
like that working probably in the Indies
but like you said nowhere nobody of that
much star power where like everybody is
but I feel like that's kind of like
almost a holdover from the 70s yeah yeah
I don't know this movie is kind of a
throwback in it it is kind of like in
the way it's structured and stuff but I
have to say like I said it's just I mean
if you like gangster movies you have to
[ __ ] say this I mean it's it's one of
the best gangster movies ever
it's a you like I said it's kind of like
a more meditative take on Goodfellas
with a lot of the same cast and a lot of
the same subject matter but it's just I
don't know there was just something
really and I can't think of the word but
it's just like I was just like riveted
the whole [ __ ] time it's got a
nostalgic to it yeah certain a nostalgic
tone to
kind of takes you back on into the olden
days even though like I wasn't I think I
was a little kid when Jimmy Hoffa died
but you know in the 80s being in the
Detroit area you know as you know as a
teenager and know in the Detroit area
kind of made me kind of reminded me of
what that what the houses look like in
that area the culture the time things
things that kind of centered around the
auto industry and unions all that shit's
gone now yeah and it was because of
stuff like this yeah the union's kind of
destroyed themselves they were [ __ ]
corrupt well in this movie kind of goes
into like a lot of [ __ ] happening about
that even though like I said the heart
of the movie is kind of like the
relationship between Frank Sheeran and
Jimmy Hoffa yeah and then also kind of
you know the conflict that develops
between him you know and his friendship
with Jimmy Hoffa and Jimmy Hoffa
becoming problematic for his kind of mob
over bosses part of the reason why you
know long the audio industry went to
them China and Mexico is because of this
[ __ ] yeah these unions you know they
[ __ ] over the cut of the audio
industry and people trying to get trying
to look for work because he couldn't get
work unless he joined that Union and
then they had to control over who joined
the Union there but gangsters yes so
it's kind of like average man couldn't
get it couldn't get a job because the
games because the unions would keep you
out you know is it so it's kind of like
a time capsule of that of that era era
yeah and like I said it spans kind of
like you know Frank Sheeran it's it's
kind of like his biopic but not really
because it's kind of like has a larger
scope but it kind of like how he first
got into you know got in with the mob
and like how he you know kind of worked
his way up through the ranks and like I
said then it kind of gets into the whole
Jimmy Jimmy Hoffa thing but like I said
don't let the three and a half hour
runtime scare you off it yeah it does
not feel like three and a half hours
it's the same as same as binge in a
series yeah and everybody binge a series
anyway
yeah see me [ __ ] we sat and watched the
the whole
confession killer I was five that was
five hours hours so just about four and
a half five same thing and it said that
didn't seem long to me
but yeah so like I said if you haven't
seen this one this is definitely one you
need to see I think this is gonna kind
of go down as a classic probably won a
bunch of awards I would imagine yeah
like other than once that it's already
won or that it's already been nominated
for so yeah on Netflix go
[Music]